[Applause]
channing tatum and sandra bullock just
wrapped their latest project and
celebrated the end of filming lost city
of d with a dip i mean a celebratory
jump in the pool
on monday the 41 year old actor posted
this clip to instagram holding his 57
year old co-star as someone off camera
announces that they have wrapped up
filming
[Applause]
pretty cute right well after they
emerged from the water they encouraged
the whole casting crew to jump in and
join them
channing also shared this underwater
shot writing that he loves the movie so
much he doesn't have words adding quote
i also don't have words for how special
sandy bullock is we were definitely made
in the same lab and share a brain at
times i love you girl and as you can see
i'll ride your coattails anywhere
anytime forever that's a high compliment
channing previously gave fans a peek at
the making of lost city of d in may when
he shared this naked selfie from the set
of the flick writing quote you know when
you in the makeup trailer whole naked
holding a towel over your junk you about
to do some [ __ ] on set that you gonna
have to prepare your mama for before she
see the movie he also poked fun at his
impressive physique writing quote and
yes i'm flexing so hard i got a cramp
i've been more than blessed in the film
which is due out april 2022 sandra plays
a reclusive romance novelist who was
sure nothing could be worse than getting
stuck on a boat tour with her cover
model played by channing until a
kidnapping attempt sweeps them both into
a cutthroat jungle adventure proving
life can be so much stranger and more
romantic than any of her paperback
fictions
it's really sweet and if that plot and
channing's abs aren't enough to convince
you to head to the theater get this
brad pitt will have a cameo in the movie
while patty harrison divine joy randolph
and daniel radcliffe round out the cast
i'm just gonna leave it at that i'll
take two tickets please but until april
2022 we'll just be here hoping channing
keeps the behind-the-scenes content
coming
[Applause]
you